this is for you i'm sure you know more
about this than i do but after 51 years
the zodiac killer's
uh little coded message was broken by
three people
and there are three random people not
like why right
uh they're private citizens one was a
software engineer another
one is a computer programmer not by like
government officials
yeah not my government regular like
citizens and they've been
one of them have been deciphered trying
to decipher this message
since 2006. peep this so the zodiac
killers
never been caught yeah he was a serial
killer in northern cali
he would kill couples they did a movie
on it zodiac killer
jake gyllenhaal uh yeah it was great
great movie
they've never caught him ever he's an
old man now if he's still out there he's
an old man now
they never caught him he was so gangster
he would kill people
and then he would terrorize the city and
send
these notes that they deciphered they
said he'd send notes
to the big outlets like the san
francisco chronicle
he sent you to the news stations he sent
[ __ ] to the police department they could
never figure out who's doing it
damn so these people just crack and they
all figure it they all had the same
uh i mean they all they all worked
together so they worked as an
old guy have you seen the documentary
don't [ __ ] with cats you know like the
facebook group found them yeah it's kind
of like this
yeah but they didn't find them they just
broke down his
note from four so they don't even know
what the guy looks like he looks
crazy though like stevie has his note
hung over the
bathroom so every time he pees he looks
at it and tries to figure it out stevie
does
yeah stevie but uh the fbi came out
after looking over it for two weeks
after it was submitted
they concluded that this is probably
gonna be what the actual message is like
no one's gotten this close
to being as accurate as they were did
they release the message they did
release the message
was it wasn't it's pretty creepy but
also
you know how the other like the
government
uh the fbi and uh nor cal the
the police department's like you know
it's an ongoing investigation
we're still gonna find justice for the
victims you ain't doing [ __ ]
nobody nobody's looking into that that
was like 40 years ago
yeah it was tough it was in the 70s
this is what it said i hope you're
having lots of fun trying to catch me
that wasn't me on the tv show which
brings up a
point about me i'm not afraid of the gas
chamber because it will send me to
paradise all the sooner
because i now have enough slaves to work
for me where everyone else has nothing
when they reach paradise so they are
afraid of death clearly a psychopath
i'm not afraid because i know that my
new life will be an easy one in paradise
you spell paradise wrong because yeah
that's the one bit that people are still
trying to figure out because
a spell paradise with the c instead of
an s and so they think that stands for
something but they don't know what that
stands for pair of dice
oh
does that mean he's in las vegas oh
and you know what was in las vegas
oj was popping in the 70s he rushed for
2000 yards for buffalo bills
and then he was the zodiac killer
don't put that on hello twitter i was on
the road
never caught them some great books on
them too oh my god wait do they think
that's him or something
no they have no idea who the [ __ ] is
that guy yeah presents
most evidence that the deceased's dad
was the zodiac so that's the death if he
is alive
he's like 90 years old oh yeah you know
the golden state killer
different guy uh yeah they caught him
like way later right dude way later
old man got life in prison and actually
the comedian
uh what's his name plays ratatouille
small guy
that nozzle patton oswald's ex-wife who
passed away
caught him oh oh yeah
and then there's a documentary on hbo
about it the golden state killer
so he would just break into people's
homes rape them and then uh would kill
some of them and just rape the others
and he was a police officer
but this in the 70s when people have
like alarms and [ __ ]
like what are we in the 70s what the
[ __ ] you doing dude
leaving the windows open it what the
[ __ ] yeah where are you guys
i thought santa claus was coming they
made it too easy for them yeah they
thought
okay yeah yep they made it too easy for
these heroes yes
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son